good evening everyone my name is David
Burtka my colleague here is Danny cohort
and today we would like to talk to about
our presentation which is about Jesus
cycle mainly we worked on a simulation
of the over diesel cycle which we want
to use for educational purposes now in
the first half my colleague who told you
something about the theory behind the
diesel cycle and something about the
historical background of this problem
and in the other half I will tell you
about what you all want to know and that
is how we worked it out in Mathematica
so I'll just pass microphone to my
colleague ok so good evening at first I
would like to speak about the rent or a
theoretical background of diesel cycle
diesel cycle is thermodynamic cycle
which was invented by rudolf diesel in
1893 there is his photo as every
thermodynamical cycle we can create PV
diagram of thermodynamic recycles there
are four important parts of the cycle
the cycle starts in the state number one
in the state the gas in the indo chamber
is compressed is compressed we have to
do some work and we move to the state
number number two in there the fuel is
injected into the chamber and then the
fuel is the fuel is expand and next next
part is expansion of this fuel in free
in the state number free there is expand
and this is very important part this is
only one part in which the daiso cycle
work and then after that we are in the
state number four in which the the air
and the rest is filled out from from
this machine and then we are back in the
state number number one if we return to
the Terra background we have to do work
in between states number one and two and
work is done between states number three
and four there are two is a central big
part in which in which heat it's not
input or output there is another part
how to calculate it out thermal
efficiency of die so cycle it depends on
many parts Oh many parameters the first
one is cut off ratio it is the ratio of
two volumes volume number three which is
there and volume number number two it is
during the Chamber's chamber chamber
chamber time next part is compression
ratio it is marked as a beam it is the
ratio of volumes number two and one and
two and duration of specific heat which
is called as a Poisson constant so there
is there is an equation of idle thermal
efficiency of a diesel cycle but of
course in practice the real efficiency
is significantly lower due to friction
and due to the lover due to the heat
losses so next part is for diesel engine
the most important thing is that diesel
engine converts heat into the work it is
used not only in the cars but in power
generations these electric locomotives
and
submarines for example the highest
thermal efficiency of any standard
internal or external combustion engine
due to its very high compression ratio
and inherent lean but which facilitates
unburned gases to scavenge waste heat if
we create real real engine the
efficiency may be about fifty percent
but usually it is more lover if we are
not so much so interested in in the mass
of this engine usually I can create a
big engine and the efficiency is heist
so there is a picture of how to some
diesel engine works and another part of
theoretical background is history there
are some important dates of diesel
engine so in the 19's or in 1891 Herbert
Stewart invents the first internal
combustion engine and later in 1892
rudolf diesel gift a patent if you use
wolfram alpha you can find some
information about love diesel a special
date of birth place of birth and for
example place of death it is English
Channel there is picture and there is
some hints per day you can see this area
because we were interested in that so
there is there is the big big peak so
after that in eighteen ninety three it
is the date of innovation diesel engine
so you can find using wolfram alpha dead
it is 120 years ago there is a picture
of brutal of diesel height compression
prototype prototype ng
in 1897 later later this engine was
applied not only into some laboratories
but in practice for example you can see
that it was used for for river and kind
of prey operation operations and for
example in Russia or in France later in
1904 1905 build the first diesel
submarine called zit in 1905 for diesel
engine turbo charges and intercoolers
very manufactured in nineteen thirty
first u.s. diesel power passenger car
was constructed built in columbus in
indiana in the USA and the last
information first european passenger
cars with diesel engines were
constructed by citroen company so that's
all about theoretical background and now
my colleague described the
implementation of diesel cycle ends of
the Mathematica thank you very much this
there was a nice introduction to this
cycle thank you very much so there is
now time to to show you how we
implemented it in Mathematica
Mathematica is very powerful tool very
rible and everyone
and it's used by many measures
throughout the world and first thing we
did was these free diagrams you have
already met the PV diagram in the
introduction then we have a pressure to
temperature diagram and lastly a
temperature temperature to entropy
diagram in the sliders up here the
student that wants to look at the these
diagrams you can change the initial
volume initial pressure and initial
temperature that define the starting
points that are in here here and here
then by just by changing the compression
ratio and cut off ratio you can see that
the efficiency of the cycle and the
whole diagrams are changing the
compression ratio is a ratio it's the
initial volume to volume after the
piston compresses the air in the
cylinder you can see that the pressure
is very high also the temperature is the
highest but it's the isentropic face so
there is no change in the entropy after
that it's a isochoric is a barrack face
I is a very face this here now described
as a very face after that be isentropic
that's the is the part when the
explosion of the fuel which comes into
contact with the hot air occurs this is
the after that it's high it's fast
expansion expansion of the volume of the
compressed volume and this part is the
part when the fumes are released from
the cylinder but just contrasting
constructing these diagrams where the
student can change just the compression
ratio cut off ratio and initial values
it's not something it's too easy for
mathematical metallica can do better so
we decided to make it a simulation in
time we constructed this little point
and by the student can run the
simulation sir and also I we applied
angular gorgeous that's did are already
in Mathematica since version 9 because
why not it's much more nicer using this
gorgeous than just a having dynamic
changes changing numbers but I can see
that animation is running too fast I'll
try to slow it down a little
it's getting slower and slower by the
time or not
this way the student can see the changes
in the volume pressure and temperature
of this cycles so there is a volume
pressure and temperature can see that we
are right now we are the in the
exhaustion face but no exhaustion the
phase where the fumes are exhausted from
the cylinder this is the one part and
the the final part was to do a 3d model
of the cylinder the piston we're on the
right side you can change the diagram
you want to watch when the Pistons
moving also they are the angular
gorgeous that were in the previous part
yeah
I think you can see that just just
adjust the animation ratio the free
should work awful let's go
unfortunately it seems that the
temperature coach is too isn't working
properly so the student can watch how
the the temperature in phase where the
compression occurs changes depending on
a compression ratios and a couple cut
off she oh you can see that when the
compression ratio is higher the
temperature of the compressed air is
also getting higher but increase with
increased cutoff ratio that is the is
loss is this part the the the
temperature is lower so you can see how
it changes in PT diagram and TS diagram
final thing is that we also compute the
overall efficiency of this of this
concrete of this cycle this initial
temperatures
so this is the final part of our
simulation and the hardest part was
implementing it in Mathematica d
equations were pretty easy and we hope
that in the near future we will make it
much more better including some some new
features thank you for our attention and
do you have any questions or what
questions do you have yes no no no it
may seem that way but it's mainly
constructed of a separate function
separate functions for each of the of
the face of each face there is a this PV
diagram PV diagram moving in time PT
diagram PT diagram in time I can go no
go on and on yeah it's I find it much
much more better to rule the function
separately and Anna just in the
manipulate to put them together and the
code is much more easier to a to
orientate it orientate in thank you
yes so the question was if this
simulation is applied in classroom yes
we we are working on it as I said and we
we constructed with the idea with the
purpose to show the students to make it
for students easier to visualize the PV
diagrams out pvp t TS or and how it
works in the cylinders because the
thermodynamical cycles are not so easy
to visualize to visualize just without
any tools so we are so there is the
question
yeah um me personally I would like to
focus more on the 3d model of the
cylinder cuz it it should it kind of get
better also we can you cannot make it
some adjustments as you could see it
wasn't running so fast the code is
really long and of course some more
output data of it would be nice yeah
thank you for a question so are there
any questions